(audience cheers)
- Welcome back everybody,
we are here with Juliet Lewis.
So Juliette stars in the
Showtime series, "Yellowjackets".
New episodes drop every Friday,
but she's also had a
successful music career
with her group Juliette
Lewis and The Licks,
which is super cool, check it out.
Because we both love music and performing
it's time to relive some of
our most memorable moments.
This is "Musical Memories:
Firsts and Worsts".
(piano plays)
- Okay so wait, I'm gonna hit this button
and either a first or a worst will appear
on the screen,
- [Juliette] Okay.
- and we'll each have to give our answers.
So let's go,
here we go.
- All right.
- I've never seen these, so...
(machine dings)
- [Juliette] Oh.
- Oh.
First song I wrote, "Baby Blue Eyes".
What was yours?
- What?
Now I just want you to sing it.
- [Kelly] Not now (laughs).
- You're so...
Can you believe-
- [Kelly] It was about a boy,
I had a crush on a boy.
- Really?
- He had baby blue eyes.
(audience cheers)
Yeah.
- How old were you when you wrote it?
- Oh, young.
I mean, probably like...
- [Juliette] 16?
- I don't know.
No, probably younger.
Probably like 13 or something.
13, 14, yeah.
- All right.
- Yeah.
- And then what do I do?
- What are yours?
What's your first song?
- First song well,
when I was talking to
a producer I was like,
you mean like a real song that I recorded
and then performed, 'cause it was that.
Or there was when I
was like playing piano.
- I want that one.
- I..
No I barely could-
It was so sad.
It was like this sad,
which shows my relationship to drama,
'cause I just loved...
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Playing these deep-
- "Baby Blue Eyes" wasn't
a happy song, yeah.
Mine wasn't a happy song, no.
- It wasn't?
Well, I like...
- Yeah it's sad.
- Yeah, okay.
- You didn't end up
with the baby blue eyes.
- Yeah, I'm trying to remember the lyrics.
So it was,
♪ I wish I could have ♪
♪ Dun dun ♪
♪ So much that I can't have ♪
(Kelly laughs)
♪ It seems awful to me ♪
And then it would go,
♪ Dun ♪
♪ If I were to die
everyone would wonder why ♪
And then it goes,
♪ It seems awful to me ♪
And then I go,
(Kelly laughs)
(audience cheers)
- You're officially my favorite guest.
- I do believe-
(machine beeps)
(Kelly laughs)
- Okay wait,
first musical icon who had you starstruck.
Oh so you met them, so...
- Yeah.
- Who was yours?
- Bob Dylan.
- Whoa.
(audience gasps)
That's a huge one.
(audience applauds)
- I know, the story is even better.
I'm in New York City, I'm working.
I walk into an elevator
that's the size of a shoebox.
- Like Europe, yep.
- Only three people
can fit in there.
And I look up, it's Bob Dylan.
He says...
(Kelly laughs)
No and then your heart
goes (explosion sound)
and all these things happen.
And then he says,
"You know Bob, huh?"
Bob De Niro.
- Yeah.
- "You were in that movie",
he says to me, and I'm like,
"And you're Bob Dylan."
(audience laughs)
And so then my little brain was like,
"Say hi, how are you?"
Because I was gonna faint.
And then I got to the van driver
who was taking me to work,
and because Bob Dylan
meant such a huge thing.
I listened to this song for months on end
called "She Belongs to Me",
through one of the hardest times
of my entire life when I was 22.
- Yeah.
- And so his lyrics were biblical to me.
They really helped me a lot.
The opening line is,
"She's got everything she needs,
she's an artist, she don't look back"
And, oh my god (laughs)
Do not cry.
- You're not crying, you're good.
You're not crying.
- Anyway,
I get in the van, I say,
"I just met Bob Dylan."
And then I promptly start sobbing,
and I was like, that poor man.
I had enough sense to like leave him,
not cry to him but,
it was really special.
- I think he probably
thought that was cool.
I think it's sad when you meet people
that you love or they've affected you
in some way and you
aren't touched like that.
- Yes.
- I think that that's a sad thing.
Maybe you're too jaded at that point.
- Yeah.
- We're too cool,
there's certain people-
- I've never been too cool.
(Kelly laughs)
- I love that.
Same.
- Ever.
My story's not gonna,
I just don't feel like,
- What's yours?
- I mean, I have several that are,
the people definitely are comparable.
I just mean like, that
was an intense situation.
Like that you were alone with that person.
- Yeah.
- But I,
I feel like might've been literally
like my favorite singer on planet Earth.
It's like a tie with
she and Trisha Yearwood,
but Aretha Franklin.
And it was like, but here's the thing.
It wasn't private.
- Excuse me,
Bob Dylan, Aretha Franklin
- But it wasn't private.
No no no.
But it wasn't private.
It was just, it was literally,
we were both at this event
and I believe it was Randy,
Randy Jackson who was like,
"Hey, you gotta come say hi",
and I was like,
"No, I don't."
I was like,
"I do not. I will look from afar."
I don't do well with people.
- Yes.
- I become an idiot.
And I, yeah, just silly.
And so he got me up there and I was like,
and she came off stage and she
literally was so nice to me.
But it was so awesome to see as an artist,
like a young artist
watching a complete legend,
and she came off and she
could not get out of her head.
She was like,
"Man, was it, it's, I felt like my vocals,
I couldn't hear the vo-"
And it was like,
"Oh my god, this is like
me coming off stage."
- [Juliette] Yep.
- I was like, "Oh so this
is never gonna change."
- Yeah.
(Kelly laughs)
- I was like, she came
off and she was like,
"I felt like I could have done better,
like, it was like my vocal, I don't know.
Did you feel the room was weird?"
And I was like, "Oh my God."
And it was like the Ghost
of Christmas Future.
Like, I was like, I was like,
"I'm never gonna
not be this person"
- It never gets better.
- Like a seasoned pro, nope.
- I know!
- You're still gonna head-
- I know, it's like still gonna, yeah.
But it kind of made me feel awesome,
like as a young artist
to watch this legend
and make me not feel crazy sometimes.
- Yes.
- Yeah.
Anyway, give it up for
Juliette Lewis everyone.
- Thanks.
(audience cheers)
- A new episode of
"Yellowjackets" premieres
this Friday on Showtime.